this magazine just got banned in a
federal prison and the backstory will
make your blood boil the justice
department told us prison officials
block delivery to an incarcerated
subscriber why our cover story on prison
guards who raped female inmates and got
away with it could be quote detrimental
to the security good order or discipline
of the institution we first covered this
in 2019 none of the prison guards were
prosecuted and many retired before being
fired allowing them to collect benefits
even worse federal prisons failed to
prevent or investigate the abuse so does
the story jeopardize the good order of
the institution
no does it make prison officials look
bad absolutely this isn't the first time
reason has been censored this issue was
blocked for its coverage of AR
accessories and cannabis reason is
appealing its latest rejection but this
story could have been avoided altogether
if prison guards were held accountable
for their crimes